why don't we go next to vincent from los
angeles what's going on in la these days
vincent
oh um nothing nothing much i haven't
been outside in a while
personally it's good to get some of that
vitamin d you know
yeah yeah um i i wanted to call in and
ask basically like i listen to your show
a lot and it's an honor to speak to you
pleasure um a lot of things
outside is really like i don't know
listening to a lot of what's going on
with
the sort of purging of the republican
party and
um gets me and you know what's going on
with climate and covid
gets me really uh nervous i was
wondering if you could
maybe talk about things that have been
going on that might give you uh
like hope as to uh you know things
getting better in the world
yeah i mean listen it's like if you uh
what might be useful for you and maybe
others is
sign up for a good news newsletter there
are a lot of these which just tell you
about good things that have gone on you
look at
how long are people living on average
after being diagnosed with all types of
cancer
survivability has gone up you look at
you know the you can
find positive things that are going on
look at the increase the continued
increased efficiency of solar panels for
example or
look at the way in which many countries
have shifted more and more
towards alternative energy you can
definitely find that stuff but
it's also a reality that there's a lot
of really bad things going on right now
i think it's important to kind of
see both you know yeah now i'm curious
when you say
you're you're not you're not not going
out
because you're depressed about all these
things that are going on and you're just
staying home right are the two things
you mentioned they're separate issues
um to some extent to some extent oh are
you like kind of depressed and just not
leaving your house
uh just dealing with some social anxiety
i don't know like
one of the greatest things that's caused
me fear is like uh
in particular like the fear of uh
nuclear
you know weaponry around the world and
that's making you
stay home in some sense
yeah yeah i mean i don't know how much i
want to
talk about it but yeah wow i mean on a
very practical level
do you think you're safer from nuclear
fallout at home
rather than you know down the street at
a cafe
because it seems either way if there's
nuclear fallout you just might be
screwed i don't know i don't know that i
would worry that much about it in that
way
that's that's a very good point i guess
i'm just thinking like if there's a if
there's a nuke that's going to be
dropped
i'd almost rather be at the basketball
court or at the pond rather than in my
house because either way it's going to
be bad and i have no control over it
that's my
thought you know yeah yeah it's
understandable
yeah try to get out there maybe take a
10-minute walk today you know
yeah you know i think i'll go ahead and
do that i like now and i'll take a look
at uh some of the
things you mentioned as to positive
signs let's do it change
let's do it and i want to hear from you
again okay let me know how it goes
okay thank you very much great talking
we gotta get out there
that's sad that makes me sad we really
you know
staying at home in order to avoid the
bomb i mean uh
i'd rather be having a cappuccino you
know i think that's the that's the
situation for me